topic i'll be speaking on today is the
relationship between data science and
DevOps before I really start I want to
just kind of see maybe a raise of hands
how many people are familiar with dev
ops or I've heard of it get an inkling
of it okay how many people don't know
what operations is what I'm saying when
I say operations a few people okay um so
I'll cover that a little bit then once I
start but I'm Kyle Snavely I'm with IBM
cloud a database service at IBM and I'm
a software engineer I use that label
because it's very generic I have a lot
of roles of cloud so we'll talk a little
bit about my engineering journey and
then we'll speak on that relationship
between data and DevOps know when I talk
about my journey I'll describe what
DevOps means to me it means to my team
and then we'll walk through an example
to live built kind of in the DevOps
culture using data science techniques to
drive a little bit more insight from the
data we have a cloud and then we'll
close it off so before I get started
I'll cover the basics i just took that
round of hands for if you hear somebody
a software engineer especially or suffer
oriented company talking about
operations usually what they're
referring to is engineers that are
managing the deployment managing the
status of a running service or product
as a customer uses it so these are
people that are going to be paged in the
middle of the night if the web site goes
down right or your database as high
latency you're going to get a page at
2am that's operations now contrast that
with development we're traditionally
we're talking about engineers who are
just developing software and almost in a
closed box you can think about it right
so they they create the software they
make a release it's a gold disc and the
hand to the operations team and they do
the thing that's the background let's go
back to me so Jenny mentioned kind of
interesting tidbit about my past I
actually wasn't
software engineer initially I always
wanted a career in software but my
education background is actually in
experimental physics and I mean it's
it's a really interesting field now I
wanted to show this picture to you just
because it brings up warm memories but
also because this is quite a complex
system though what this is is a cryostat
that houses semiconductor detectors for
the my Rana experiment and there's a lot
going on here I mean there's a vacuum
sensor you know somebody designed this
this vacuum cryostat housing we've got
all these wires going to detectors so
what's really going on is this entire
design it's being driven by data right
and so data is kind of giving us the
description for a solution to this
complex problem and as I move from
physics of software engineering its data
that kind of remains the commonality
make sense and a lot of people tell me
that's a curious path to take from
physics to software but I don't think so
and I'm willing to bet that this
audience probably doesn't think so when
you're solving a complex physics problem
you're doing the same thing that you do
for an engineering problem a software
problem you are breaking it down with
analytic reasoning and you're examining
the problem data such that you
understand the problem sufficiently to
find a solution so data is a common
ground linking these fields in other
fields we must well understand our data
to enact an effective solution so this
is my physics back in the day kind of
got tired of working a mile under down
in a mine for like 10 hours straight so
I jumped a JumpShip and i joined cloud
as 5 on developer so cloud what is this
thing I've been talking about well cloud
and say database service so it's an
always-on manage database service set
that's offered by IBM rid my folks like
me operated by folks like me and cloud
was acquired in IBM 2014 which is kind
of what brings
in front of all of you today cloud you
can think of as a you know amazon dynamo
version of apache couchdb so it exposes
a very similar interface almost exactly
the same as patty couchdb but it offers
features like clustering sharding data
replication things like that and you
know we have thousands machines across
the globe hundreds of clusters so and
cross multiple data centers data
providers we've got legacy data centers
we've got brand spankin new ones all
kinds of stuff and what this means is
that cloud is an exercise in operating
distributed systems and that's extremely
difficult you know it's enough to deal
with one machine running out of this
space but it's an entirely different
problem when that data is associated
with another replica data set on
machines that are communicating over a
network serving customers and maintain
themselves at the same time it's a huge
pain and so cloud was kind of my first
exposure into what it takes to really
operate a global service and I'm really
lucky to have joined this team because I
think they do an excellent job you know
cloud tries to embrace customer
challenges we want the service to work
for the customer and it's also where I
started to maybe understand DevOps even
before I knew what the term was because
there are engineers a cloud that kind of
embody that spirit of DevOps and I've
been fortunate to work alongside them
okay so we've made it to the buzzword
stage I hate buzzwords I think as an
engineer they devalue what you actually
do day to day but there is I think some
value in this tournament and maybe the
awareness of this term so back in the
day what DevOps originally was kind of
scene asked was breaking down that wall
between the development group and the
operations group that i prescribed right
if you're throwing a gold disc over the
wall and then they're trying to run that
in production trying to understand what
kind of
are happening it's just been proven not
to work that well and for a lot of teams
breaking down those barriers combining
those people and knowledge of
development operations has proven to be
very effective for bettering their
product or service and there's a few
components to DevOps you know at the
kind of Vegas level I like to think
about it as a culture it's one that
encourages collaboration across teams
you know cross-functional teams as well
as just knowledge sharing /
communication between those teams and
another part of it I think perhaps the
most important part is the people if you
have an engineering culture that
embraces that knowledge sharing and
communication and you have engineers
that understand the software development
lifecycle as well as the
responsibilities and the knowledge
required to manage offering the team
will go very far and when you have that
culture and those people naturally you
kind of get I think what a lot of people
think about with DevOps which is the
ease of rapid iteration or adopting
agile process for your team okay and
there's a few other big things too like
embracing continuous automation I mean
that's a huge thing we'll get back to
but it can be super simple I mean you
see infographics online that will go on
for pages about DevOps and it's just a
waste of space you know when I think
about DevOps I think about maybe you
know a database engineer and and she's
been you know working on CouchDB for
years but now she's a clot and she wants
to contribute to the operations
organization so this person is moving
out of the comfort zone perhaps on their
own time learning things like chef for
configuration management or maybe just
you know system management skills
learning to be a sis event but then when
she goes back to her database
programming I can guarantee you she has
a fuller understanding of the context in
which her software is going to be
running and she'll understand exactly
what it means the importance of our
service operating all the time
it really does change the way you code
on the flip side you have operators that
benefit from this culture I think
sometimes maybe it's ops that benefits
the most maybe it maybe somebody's can
get mad at me for saying that but you
know I picture somebody maybe has just
finished her education they have a
background of a system administrator or
perhaps an infrastructure engineer but
they start to pick up you know software
engineering skills so now instead of you
know solving problems may be manually on
the command line they're reaching out
tools they're improving these tools the
tools are shared between teams and the
organization and it's you know
effectively a force multiplier for their
ability to operate the service I mean
and these are examples i'm giving you
but these are things i have seen happen
and have a positive impact on on
everybody on the team and so the second
part of this how is DevOps driven by
data why am I talking to you today well
I posit that both operations and
development have data at the core and
they have to understand that their data
to make decisions every day so maybe
let's look a little bit closer at clock
because i'll be using these data sources
in an example in a few minutes well we
have a lot of data cloud we might not be
petabyte scale but for instance splunk
we use if you're not familiar splunk is
a log aggregation engine as very
simplistic description it offers some
pretty advanced features some alerting
and we push nearly a terabyte of logs to
splunk a day for my service that's a lot
of data to make a decision from wees
fogbugz which is like a work management
system might be kind of curious fogbugz
a ticket system as he's not really
returning numerical data what the data
can be useful and I'll give an example
of that later well finally graphite now
maybe that's the most important data
source maybe the wrong port but graphite
is our system metrics storage engine say
for lack of a better term it also
exposes some pretty advanced feature
in terms of querying data basic
operations you can perform on data and I
think we pull in a 12 gigabytes of day
of system metrics data not terabyte of
logs but still the chunk and so
developers will use these sources while
developing a feature you know they might
be tracking their work in a ticket or
trying to understand how a customer has
been using or misusing an existing
feature by examining logs of course
operations they're going to live and die
by these right you can incident at 2am
you are opening metrics and you are
opening splunk to figure out what's
going on and and anywhere ghen is that
any organization you know the
interactions with the service of their
product is going to be governed by
observations of their computing
environments application metrics system
logs and we can do a lot with these data
sources right I mean I sure you cloud
ins work really hard let's do their job
for instance Splunk offers a lot of
features on its UI you can do some
pretty advanced searching as long as you
can pay the spunk bill and we've built
monitoring and alerting on top of
graphite that's why I said perhaps it's
the most important system we have it's
going to be the thing that it pages you
when disk usage is slow or when you've
run out of memory on a machine but in
the course of you know my career as a
developer and operator just a guy with a
lot of hats a cloud I started to see
some inefficiencies and how we use these
data sources and you know part of that's
driven you know perhaps by an operations
process where you're you know you're
constantly engaging with systems issues
and customer tickets I mean I mentioned
we have thousands of machines
something's always failing it's just a
continuous state of hardware failure
right it's nothing you can do about it
but when an issue occurs you know people
are considering these data sources
separately you get your splunk tab open
you've got your graphite tab open maybe
our advanced metrics
web page does some some extra special
stuff but you know it's a human kind of
piecing this data together on the fly
trying to understand you know what
what's the context of this incident what
portion of the system has failed in a
way that we were alerted or that the
customer is complaining and you know I
think that we can dive a little deeper I
mean this is just data right i mean
that's data butts planking and graphite
those guys are dated too so maybe let's
look a little deeper here and now before
i continue is everyone feel a little bit
more comfortable at developed in
operations okay like to non sounds good
that's pretty good response from 0
conference signs all right so they've
got me a cloud doing all these things
and sometimes I I get a bit naughty and
I do something like a small research
project right so a few years ago I was
kind of working intensively a lot of
large customers trying to figure out how
we can improve our pasty planning a
cloud so this means you know you're a
client of ours and you expect your user
base to grow over the next two years
well the predictions of the growth of
your company are going to drive the
investments you make in terms of
something like a data service right
you're paying money for things like dis
space I you know request operations and
when you get down to the bottom of it
we're talking about machines right
you're talking about hard drives Ram all
that good stuff you know although as a
service we hide that from the customers
as much as possible when's the last time
you know you saw a disk usage alert from
gmail right and I've had this previous
experience kind of as a scientist so I
I'd use some of these tools before years
ago and luckily many members of the
cotton team are actually kind of X
scientists may be disgruntled maybe not
I don't know a lot of physicists there
it's kind of suspicious but we basically
developed tool to dive a little deeper
into things like splunk and graphite and
it's still a kind of ongoing research
project but there are a lot of people in
my
ization excited about this so I've
called this thing forecast and what it
is is an analysis engine what it does is
novel things that our current data
sources aren't capable of right things
like splunk and graphite and five bucks
they'll expose API so we can fetch data
from and by putting them on a common
common well say a common language like
pandas right now we've eliminated the
the impedance mismatch between say our
splunk logs in our graphite data and
because we can pull in things like dump
I or whatever scientific programming
python library you want you can do some
pretty advanced analysis right basically
anything you can do in Python you can
alert on I mean that's pretty amazing
and then also I pulled it cute pure
matplotlib for some visualization now
forecast is an engine doesn't really
make graphs it just gets data chews on
it and sends that data somewhere else
but I use Jupiter matplotlib for
development and it's awesome of course
you all know that now I'm going to
demonstrate some things the forecast can
do I'm going to tell you right now
they're going to be simple but they're
going to be powerful you know those
tools are so easy to use you know we've
got tutorials in this conference that
teach you the basics an hour and a half
they could radically change how you you
know do your job as a data scientist or
do your job as an engineer and this is
where that marriage between DevOps and
data becomes really powerful because we
can take those tools and we can put them
in something like an automated
monitoring system okay and that can be a
super powerful you know for instance one
problem we have in operations is false
positives right your CPU just spiked to
ninety nine percent so what I paid for
that cpu I'm glad to utilize it right
but maybe that ninety-nine percent cpu
usage is correlated with some other poor
behavior maybe your database doesn't
respond now it's not a false positive
right
and because we're pulling in those logs
from splunk we can go beyond what's punk
can do and now spunk offers some pretty
advanced features but you're still kind
of locked into that you I if you want to
do something really radical with that
data you have to wait for spunk to do it
or write some kind of plug in yourself
but because we already have a lot of
Python that cloud that describes our
service its service library layer we
just decided to use these tools and pull
the data into a central location one
example of how you could use this engine
is in an incident response system so the
manager gets paged at 1am because the
customer is very upset they could press
one or two buttons and have forecast
look at the last week of cluster health
right and start to pick out what might
be bad behaviors and give operations
some pointers on where to look and this
is where I think fog was could be very
useful because I think we all have a
good grasp of how to look through
numerical data but in this incident
management scenario it would be also
really useful to say look at the dates
and times of every ticket open by that
customer during the support of support
time right then you can compare those
ticket opening times to any bad behavior
you found in metrics and that will give
you may be a little bit more complete
understanding for something like an RCA
which is very important or another
example perhaps my favorite will it's
kind of a predictive application that's
what one of my examples would go into
but by having forecasts running in an
automated way we can do some simple
analysis all the time over all of our
metrics or whatever metrics were
interested in so we can do things like
Warren manager or their client months
before an issue is going to become
critical okay and we'll examine that
case in just a moment so
data scientists sure do love to abuse
databases but that's okay operations job
security perhaps but this space as an
operator is one of my biggest pet peeves
such a simple problem this space is a
limited resource right don't put too
much data on disk and when you run out
of disk space it becomes a huge pain in
the ass I mean systems circuit here very
strangely when they can't write to the
files that expect and not only that but
the incidents you know running out of
this space or coming nearer to running
out of disk space costs a lot more to
manage as that instant becomes more
critical you know if you're warned two
months ahead of time that you're going
to run out of disk that's great your
sales people can engage your customer
and probably upsell them or whatever you
know you need to do for your product but
if you wait until the eleventh hour and
the customers application is no longer
performing correctly in the middle of
the night they're gonna be pissed off
and some cost you a lot more time money
engineers and customer trust to fix that
problem so how can data science help
this will be my first example of the day
for forecast let me switch over to Maya
ipython notebook okay the codes not so
important but can you guys generally get
the gist of that so the first thing
we're going to look at is what I call a
disk report from forecast what forecast
is doing is it's using graphite to
examine the disk free on cluster pretty
basic stuff and this is kind of a this
is forecasts language right here it's a
configuration file that's Python [ __ ]
here but I like to think of it as more
of a JSON blob I'm kind of an HTTP API
person and we've done some simple things
here we've specified the cluster we're
interested in I picked just a major
multi-tenant cluster and I've also
specified a few analyses for forecast to
do the first is a linear fit which is
something that graphite can do but we
get a little bit more information from
dump I you know we can get parameters
regression numbers
we can do something other than letting
your fit if you feel like it and I'm
also asking forecast to give us a
prediction for win this cluster when the
nodes in the cluster are going to run
out of disk space ok now this is an
approximation this is a linear fit on
real data but I think it's very
informative so let's go ahead and I've
already run all these because it's a
deathtrap to try to do it during
conference so after asking forecasts
processor report just gives us back more
JSON it's got the original configuration
in there as well as the data fit data
fit parameters end of disc data you know
whatever you've asked for and you know
one operation method forecast is to
shove that in a database and we'll check
it out if it's relevant but we're going
to check it out right now we're going to
visualize it with matplotlib ok
beautiful graph by the way I love
systems data it's just so amazing i mean
i've seen so much physics data in my
time just beautiful interactions of
nature and then you know you log into
metrics during some horrible incident
and a customer's pissed and you just see
some awesome data yeah alright this is
awesome data sort of because it's
trending down at a precipitous rate but
the great thing is you know we fit this
with our linear regression and forecast
has predicted when the nodes in this
cluster are going to run out of disk
space this doesn't take very long either
I mean this is three months of data and
I think forecasts private process is
this and you know three seconds on my
laptop or something so on a real machine
that's you can do this over hundreds of
clusters thousands of closest if you
need to weekly basis is fine this is low
frequency monitoring right but this is
something that our real-time monitoring
system is not capable of doing and if
you have a monitoring system running on
forecasts that can access information
like this you know when a cluster is
going to run a disk that's extremely
powerful I mentioned you know we're
automating this over all of our clusters
and you can imagine those clusters are
associated with clients that have
salespeople technical account managers
well forecast sees something like this
for a cluster they can send that a soft
warning out to the team you know it will
chat the operations
on slack right before their team meeting
and say hey this cluster is gonna be in
a bad state in about a month or two you
should really take a look that's a lot
better in terms of planning what your
operations engineer is going to be doing
than getting a page when it hits 90
percent and suddenly it's a priority
okay and I mean it's so simple right
linear regression but this is extremely
powerful capability for a monitoring
service to have okay I'm gonna flip back
to my slideshow try to flip back all
right that was pretty simple it was cool
but simple ah but I got a lot more data
than disk usage right more data comes
more problems okay I mentioned you know
one thing we're not capable of doing in
a programmatic way two days comparing
data sets from spunk and graphite easily
of course that's extremely important
because you want a time correlate any
issues right so I've got an example of
disparate data sets here that and I'm
going to try to demonstrate the
importance of of correlation and I'm
under no impression that correlation
equals causation for any of these
examples so this is radar imagery and
you're probably most of you are familiar
with the top one radar reflectivity of
objects and in the environment the
darker the color the more radar has been
reflected so you're talking about water
and dust and birds and down here we have
a win to your map which is showing us in
red and green you know whether the wind
is moving away or towards the radar
source in in sort of radial fashion and
what we're doing here is looking for
signs of tornadoes right tornadic
activity but the problem is you can't
you know just rely say on this top data
set right these features that are
circled are certainly indicative of
tornadic event but on their own they're
you know not entirely meaningful right
you wouldn't go warn a county of 300,000
people if you saw this on your radar
screen
but when we combine this data set with
the wind shear and we see behavior such
as this low-level convergence or
psychotic behavior combined with a
reflectivity data now we do understand
the problem and we know that we can go
alert people with confidence we're not
giving them a false positive and that we
better understand what's happening
meteorol meteorological II and I put the
link for where this came from down below
its kind of course recommended so in
complex systems we have to rationalize
multiple data sources or maybe multiple
sets of data from one source okay it's
often operations that has to do this
right they're looking through these
signals through the radar imagery trying
to figure out is this a tornado is this
a hurricane is this nothing and using
forecast we can make these kinds of
comparisons okay mouse kill all right
let's zip down to the next example it's
going to be a little bit more complex
but nothing too crazy I mentioned CPU
and latency before that's often
correlated together during an incident
so let's explore that space here's a
forecast config for this it's similar to
that disk usage report except i'm
requesting cpu information and latency
information and the my favorite thing
about this is that these are two
different data sources right is this
graphite and the spock this is something
could do for and i've specified an
analysis on both of these what I call a
peak threshold analysis or a you know a
slow requests analysis and all its
looking for is advanced where we've
exceeded a threshold you know any time
your CPU use gone above ninety seven
percent or any time you're Layton sees
are above three seconds it's going to
log that fin and then it does one extra
step it also investigates for any time
spans with multiple events I forget what
did I use here's six six hundred seconds
says 10 minutes it's looking for any
time that multiple
events have happened in 10 minutes and
that's a maybe especially informative so
we'll keep track of those time spans and
we do that for CPU as well as latency so
it's a very similar generic analysis so
we go ahead and ask forecast for this
data it goes and fetches it for us we'll
use some sweet Matt plot living alright
resume data data first so this is a you
know a week of cpu utilization from this
cluster lots of interesting behavior
perhaps nothing that i would stand out
and jump up and down about you know if i
was looking at this data manually trying
to maybe understand why an incidence
recurring i definitely be investigating
you know Sadie be one it's got these
interesting kind of cpu humps but you
know utilization is one of those things
like i mentioned where you know you're
paying for all of it so it's okay if
you're using most of it all of it but
you know once you start hitting the wall
game over so let's look at some of the
analysis results and so these are time
spans in UNIX epoch time for these
various database nodes and which they've
exceeded that 97% cpu utilization
threshold within 10 minutes and you'll
see a very similar thing for latency and
this is going to become kind of our our
comparison measure for correlating
events between these two data sources ok
let's take a look at a latency this is
me a lot of data and I don't want
anybody to get too hung up on these data
sets I was really just trying to
demonstrate these abilities and finish
this talk on time so this is an example
of latency percentiles as as we get from
splunk i filtered out a lot of requests
that are kind of internal to our
services maybe what a customer would see
of course everyone's using the database
differently so there's a lot of
different requests going on here but the
important thing is i look foreign ops
would be the ninety-nine point nine
percent latency percentile as well as me
to the 99 percent lanes percentile so
these are going to be kind of you know
the first Inklings of an impact on your
service a first a hint that you
requests are starting to slow down your
customers are going to be unhappy as
their applications become unresponsive
and you're going to have to engage this
operational incident and just like the
CPU example I gave we've got these time
spans for where we violated the
threshold of three seconds okay and now
here's kind of the special sauce let's
compare these data sets you know these
time spans are the same types of
information and so it is actually pretty
trivial and indeed i filtered out some
of this data I can't remember just
because there's a lot of it so for this
presentation let's check out DB one and
it's ninety-nine point nine percent
latency percentiles each of these time
spans represents an overlap in the
detection of multiple incidents in
either data source and so what forecast
is telling us here is that there's some
kind of interesting property between CPU
and latency right now and if I'm an
operator using forecast I can use
something like this to narrow down where
my investigation is and it's not just
cpu and and latency any data source we
can pull in forecasts and described in
units of time spans we could do this or
correlative analysis for and I think
this will be one of forecasts more
powerful features when I spoke about
that incident management response tool
this is a sort of thing I'm envisioning
you know we can do this analysis for
memory disk ops and latency and see if
maybe it's a file system cache issue
that's causing our problem we need to
cpu and latency we can do a network and
anything else so this is very cool and
i've got a little visualization i had a
heck of a time trying to get this to
look good for you guys but i want to
give you a brief example so here's a the
latency and cpu datasets overlapped okay
and then here's the horrible part here's
a graph of each of these time spans okay
so unfortunately it's not gonna be super
easy to compare if you guys can remember
where those were you can see we
definitely have you know some bad
behavior from latency correlating with
some of these higher cpu peaks okay
correlation is not causation but it's
definitely more informative and say
I'm gonna step away from the mic these
two peeps right here these latency Peaks
that are sticking up that's not
correlated with you know any CPU issues
and vice versa we're definitely getting
pretty high on the cpu graph at times
here but it's not impacting our
latencies so this is good information
must switch back to my slides we go okay
so those forecasts it's a simple tool
it's kind of still ongoing I'm come from
the primary developer but everyone is
very excited about the possibilities in
this tool it's not just about DevOps
till all right and I'm speaking to you
as an engineer in my experiences as an
engineer are shaping the way that I've
communicated these topics of this topic
to you but you're all primarily dia
scientists so besides you know me saying
data science is cool what I want to get
out of this for you guys is to
understand that you can adopt some
elements of the DevOps culture as data
scientists and perhaps you know make
your own process more effective and that
comes with a clear leave the buzzword at
the door maybe you don't even have an
ops team in your organization right but
the culture of knowledge sharing and
collaboration is is you know without a
bound on on who you're talking about
there you know and if you're talking and
if maybe you're a pure data scientist
your organization has some developers go
sit with them talk about their
application do code review together you
know get that knowledge sharing going on
and no matter you know what the domain
is it's going to improve and finally one
of the most important lessons of DevOps
is automation so if any of you are doing
some kind of repetitive task I know I've
been there as physicists working with
you know ipython notebooks okay I'll
just do this analysis I'll just do this
one by hand on like 10 more later you're
done right well if you've written a tool
to automate some of that process for you
might have been able to save a lot of
time and it's also something that you
could then later build on which is you
know maybe the most powerful part you
know as your team comes together you
start to grow an ecosystem of tools that
I allow you to much more effectively
manage whatever it is that you're doing
so DevOps I think it's proven itself to
be very effective for a lot of teams out
there and I hope that I've demonstrated
today that data science tools and
techniques can only help to further you
know that goal that's all i had today
thank you all very much